now uh you have uh you have some
interesting news to tell us about
tonight something to share with the
class
um i did uh i actually talked about it
on the show before i did it
uh last week i did uh i was on celebrity
jeopardy you were a contestant on
celebrity gym yes i was
and um i took a camera crew with me
because i was kind of nervous about you
know
there's a big chance i would look like
an ass on national tv
i mean aside from what i normally do
right and uh
so i i i prepared you know i really sort
of
got down and made sure that you know
tried to increase my chances of doing
well yeah i heard you spent a day or so
preparing before you went to jeopardy
exactly and
i had a camera crew with me to sort of
you know just sort of chronicle
my sort of my journey from a man
preparing to to going to slay the beast
exactly and and you won't we can't tell
you how it ended up eventually because
you know the jeopardy people are kind of
touchy about that uh
so but trebek's real uptight isn't he
tell me about it dude
uh so and who did who are you up against
what's celebrating against brian danahee
and assa patha merkerson from law and
order okay which has a spin-off now
exactly all right so uh so
we'll let's just show it this is my uh
my preparation to be on celebrity
jeopardy
okay so uh in preparing for celebrity
jeopardy i
i wanted to get some help so i decided
uh
to call on the smartest person i knew to
sort of help tutor me
randall to see if he could help now tony
have you ever been on
celebrity jeopardy yes i was and how did
you do
i should have won it's really a question
of the thumb
the buzzer yes buzzer skills they've
never asked me back again
really and i've asked you right
yeah but i mean i i'm new meat
well i suppose one must face one's own
mortality and
the inevitability of a decline in the
career
and the forgetfulness of the public and
indeed the
fading memories of those who give us
jobs i'm not bitter
oh you're talking about you i thought
you were talking about me for oh okay
i'm finished oh okay my opponents are
brian dennehy
and s uh essentia merkerson yes
brandon he's a very literate man yeah
well-read
he's read eb white wow
and you know that's not is that
charlotte's web yes
um yeah but i read charlotte's web when
i was seven years old
then you're way ahead of him all right i
can only tell you don't be afraid
well you know i've actually i've got
some visual aids to help me overcome my
fear
here i i've got um
i've had these made i'm sure you noticed
them already
but i just have been standing in between
them
well it's rather daunting oh sorry
oh ms merkerson so sorry
yes alex this is jonathan groth
he's uh the head writer at late night
with conan o'brien
and also um was it five-time jeopardy
champion
yeah i won five times and i went to the
tournament of champions in 1995.
jonathan what is a parsec yes for a
thousand what are sort of the basic
tips i mean you know what are there like
i i hear rumors of buzzer tips
take that okay you really want a
fast action like that see that and
actually you want to kind of
hit it a couple times really fast like
that
and i assume you've been doing that for
the last couple weeks
no i found this article this interview
with dennehy and where he says he quotes
reads a lot and that kind of worried me
personally i don't think dennehy is
going to be the problem i think it's
going to be essa patha merkerson
i know what do you know about her
well uh you know law and order uh
acclaimed stage actor impression
impassioned and gritty yet approachable
style
but the thing that really sticks uh
it really makes me worry she was uh reba
the male lady on peewee's playhouse
is a real problem i don't know what
you're gonna do i took a scene from
law and order and i uh doctored it a
little just
uh to help motivate me watch this
i found something it's a handwritten
note in her palm pilot
it's the bomb call me and it signed
kelly
there's a phone number and a time 12 30
last night
her parents said the little angel went
to bed at 10 30.
pretty mean but
from the sony pictures studios
this is jet party
this is pretty much my practice method
let's go with television history
alex this first host of the tonight show
emceed meeting of mines for pbs in 1977.
clear one see this is right up my alley
no too bad
this bishop's talks on life is worth
living competed against milton berle
player one
good guess but no emily
before we were taping i was getting
everything right
wrong oh i'm sorry that's wrong
that is incorrect
anyone player three i'm doomed okay uh
it's pretty late
um gotten some good work on the
playstation though some good practice
i'm feeling good uh
car's gonna be here to pick me up in
like eight hours so i'm not gonna get a
whole lot of sleep
but it's gonna be good sleep because
i feel like a winner you know i'm gonna
just stay focused
tomorrow
[Music]
does andy get up this early in the
morning
big day how are you doing i'm doing all
right how are you
good i bet you i worked later last night
than you did uh what time you worked
till
11 o'clock all right uh you know what no
it's about the same time
is it yeah yeah we're shooting this
thing because he calls that work
well what were you doing reciting lines
yeah the salesman the big one
[Music]
so you're up against sean colvin and
michael bowman
oh really yeah she's going to take us
down do you think do you think is that
what you think yeah i get the sense
she's going to take us down
seems to have a wide array of knowledge
who has the best buzzer skills
of the three of you i think coleman's
got the rhythm down i mean i think she's
got
she's got the edge rhythmically and
educationally my only hope is that
every category is about me or my family
i'm up against uh s
and patha merkerson
and then uh brian dennehy oh that way
he's just gonna
intimidate through physically he's uh
[Applause]
[Music]
who won who lost
did anyone get violent to find out
you'll have to check your local
nicely done thank you
you can't say what happened i can't say
what happened okay well we'll leave it
sometime in in mid-november sometime in
mid-november what i was told watch for
the epic struggle yes
just watch every jeopardy until then
jeopardy people love this
yeah yeah they're gonna love it all
right well we're gonna take a little
break right now good work andy when we
come back
jon stewart going to be joining us